and cut hi I'm Caroline I'm at house of
moves in Los Angeles and today I'm going
to learn how to act for motion capture
I'm gonna get suited up I don't know
what I'm gonna look like on screen but
let's find out house of moves has been
the stage for many projects in TV film
and video games that involve motion and
performance capture I've seen plenty of
videos of actors wearing these suits
covered in dots or ping-pong balls do
they have what it takes to be the next
Cesar or Aleta to coach me through it we
met with one of the best in the business
Richard Doran he's a professional motion
capture actor and a teacher at the mocap
vaults his resume is extensive if you
played a video game
you've probably killed me he gave me
some valuable acting tips and then I put
them to the test
[Applause]
but first a little background on motion
and performance capture motion capture
came out of the medical industry they
were capturing the moves of people walks
their gates they were studying it for
medical reasons as it moved into the
entertainment industry the motion
capture was used for videogame
characters and performance capture that
grew out of the poll were expressed the
movie with Tom Hanks he coined the
phrase performance capture because we
were now capturing the body with the
face and with the voice motion and
performance capture are responsible for
some amazing performances now it was my
turn to get suited up not in she or
anything so it's pretty comfortable like
it's kind of like your workout clothes I
was covered head-to-toe in these
reflective markers which are actually
made from ground-up glass they'll help
capture movement from all different
parts of my body there's some sort of
miracle of Technology I was going to be
transformed into one of the creatures
from the 2016 online game Paragon I
would be a character named crux and this
soldier but first I had to get a
full-body scan your range of motion we
do this so that we can when we put the
animated character on top of you we can
see that it has a full range of motion
it's just basically of getting the
system to recognize your skeleton in the
game industry we have to fake everything
and motion capture is all about pure
imagination so you have to imagine the
environment you have to create the
environment with your body and with that
it was time to start faking
the seen a dark grimy subway station I
started off as drugs
needless to say crux doesn't look
anything like me
so for grukk's we want this big hulking
character right but we've now got to
bring the weight and the heaviness to
this character because he's vicious
character so it's all about how you
center yourself how you sender your
weight walking is really important we
want to figure out how how he moves how
how we can stay center and you're
holding a breath yeah everything you
need to breathe because your breath is
gonna help create this character you
know it was a little nerve-wracking at
first but after a while I started to get
the hang of it how does he breathe Doron
told me to find the animal that grukk's
is most similar to and try to imitate
what that real-life animal is like we
landed on a rhino once I could walk like
a mocap monster I had to adjust to
holding weapons so let's give you
something swing oh okay wow I'm sweating
and now because these are lighter weight
they're lightweight you have to bring
the weight to them you have to make them
heavy but you're a big you're a big
creature so there goes their arm
strength so they're pretty heavy that's
good but let's just take a let's just
take a swing to the right and to the
left maybe the most important part a
trademark roar
okay it's gonna be loud that's that's
why we're here we just have to find
where where this monster is inside of
you you're a very happy nice person
you've got to get angry you've got to
get a little tough you gotta get a
little meaner once I felt more
comfortable and found a character
motivation I was ready to fight
[Music]
don't don't tell me
please don't so creating that kind of
care you know monster heavy characters
that's that's one thing that we do the
other now you have to be a believable
person okay well now I'm gonna do the
soldier huh god I'm losing my voice
already I really got into character
there there were some key differences to
playing the soldier this time my breaths
had to be quieter rather than being big
and intimidating my body movements
needed to express plausible fear
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and the real key to giving a great mocap
performance is actually pretty
straightforward the technology has
really helped performance capture I mean
there were certain things we couldn't do
early on couldn't cross our arms because
the markers would get blocked I tell my
students don't let the technology
interfere with your performance if
that's not your job your job is to
perform and the post-production it's
their job to fix it if they need to this
was awesome this was unlike anything
I've ever tried before I am exhausted
I'm losing my voice from all the
growling and all the movements that I
was doing like once you kind of get into
the character you feel like it's it
comes like second nature to you with
like you don't feel like you're wearing
a suit or anything and like your weapons
become your actual weapon I think the
most important thing Richard taught me
it was to really get in character and
just imagine everything like imagine
where I am imagine where the character
is and just go for it
it's my runway walk